I want to do hard things so I have three
trigger words scary difficult and hard
if I say it if I think it if I feel it I
have to do it just because even if it's
completely unrelated if I say oh that's
too hard now I have to do it because I
want to be the person who does hard
things not for anybody for me like what
I might find hard you might think dude
that you find hard that's ridiculous but
it's hard for me so I don't want to
accept hard as a good enough reason for
me not to do something because all of
our greatest Ambitions and goals are in
the other side of scary difficult and
hard so the fact that it's if I say one
of those three things I have to go off
and do that thing and so that's that's a
push that's a that is a that is a push
forward to say I must go do this I want
to grow and learn and be better hey it's
EV car Michael and I watch these videos
every day because I need them for
motivation being around successful
entrepreneurs every morning helps me
believe that I can do great things too
it's like your morning coffee but for
your goals kickstarting your day with a
blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching one video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
# believe in the comments below so I can
celebrate with
you so today let's learn from me and my
team's take on my top 10 rules of
success enjoy rule number two is don't
fear failure I didn't want to live with
the regret of not knowing and so I told
myself I'd rather KN one fail than not
knowing even even if it didn't work out
at least I would know because I didn't
want to I would I didn't want to be an
old man at 40 is what I would tell
myself when I'm 40 and life is over and
and you're finished you know you look
back on your life you're going to regret
not knowing so that got me into the in
the path of starting my first business
uh you know struggled failed some of the
worst years of my life eventually built
and sold I don't know how deep you want
to go into that stuff but coming out of
high school I mean I had a lot of
entrepreneurial drives and tendencies
but didn't really know where to put them
and so I'm really grateful that I
discovered entrepreneurship and if you
keep keep trying and keep improving and
keep getting better you will not suck
anymore so that's where a lot of people
struggle they know it looks good they
feel they can make it they can't at the
beginning and so they stop trying in
terms of keeping going how do you keep
going when you're struggling and and
failing and not seeing the results
people ask me this all the time where
you know it took me five years to get to
5,000 subscribers or whatever close
numbers like that where a lot of people
on they're they're hitting that in the
first few months it took me 5 years to
get there I like sharing the journey
because it's it's great to see three
million whatever now but five years
5,000
subscribers uh what kept me going
through those days was I always focus on
who I was serving instead of who I'm not
rule number three is be a good
Storyteller in the book there's there's
the structure of how to do a perfect
thought leadership piece of content I
would hone in on that I I would guess
you would be great at your
storytelling you could easily tell a
three four five minute story or more
your story mind story uh somebody you've
mentored um something you see happening
with young real estate agent salespeople
addicts like there's lots of stories you
could tell I think you'd be great at
that I think the Practical advice piece
You' probably be great at that too so
okay to solve this problem do one two
three step one do this and I'm sure you
could you've just had enough experience
you can you can even you had a point
form you can talk to those points and be
eloquent and and tons of value where
most people struggles is the opening so
you got to hit me with something that
you believe that that most people would
find different or weird rule number four
is never quit the biggest failure I had
was I quit on my business partner so the
this is why I try to encourage people to
keep going and believe and all because
that was me because I needed it because
because 20-year-old Evan that badly
needed that message we were not having
success I was a year in on this business
I turned down my dream job to to take
this you know company opportunity all my
friends were were were getting rich
doing all this stuff and I was too poor
to go hang out with them and I was too
embarrassed to tell them that I was
broke right they want to hang out and I
can't because 20 bucks for pizza and
beer and then like bowling night or
whatever would be too much right and so
I said I can't I'm hustling I'm living
the entrepreneur life you know not I
like that I can't I make 300 bucks a
month guys I can't afford this so at
some point it just got to a breaking
point where I can't handle this anymore
you know I'm I'm I'm busting my butt
like every day wake up it's dark I go to
my partner's condo it's dark I leave and
go home right being salad for lunch
every day just day in day out if you
weren't working hard and you're not
getting results that's fine you can kind
of understand but when you're grinding
every single day all day and have no
other life and you're still not getting
results I don't know I think at some
point it just beats you down this to to
I can't take this anymore and so at a
family event um I was Christmas or
Thanksgiving or whatever um I told my
business partner like I can't do this
anymore I need I need to feel like I'm a
valuable
person uh and just this isn't working
and so I I quit and then I I cried like
crazy had stuff come out of my eyes my
nose you know I was just totally lost
and um the next day I woke up and felt I
can't quit yet because I'm going to
regret if I quit now I know again when
I'm an old man at 40 I'm going to regret
this life-changing decision but I can't
keep going the way that I'm going I I
have to find something else because this
is not working as it is and that's where
I had a aha moment at kind of at my
bottom which was I'm not the first guy
to try to build software before and sell
it like who's done this and the first
guy I thought of was Bill Gates who
started Microsoft so I thought okay how
did Bill Gates do it I'm GNA learn his
story and maybe there's something I can
learn from it and and I did I looked at
how Microsoft got started not not how
did he make an MI an extra million
dollars now like who cares you know
makes a million dollars a second just
just sitting around how did he go from
zero to one that's what I wanted to do
and I looked at a story and copied that
strategy and shortly after I had my
first deal for $1 135,000 in my business
and um you know grand scheme of things
that's not a lot of money but holy cow
when you're making 300 bucks a month and
you get a 13k deal my dude it's it's
it's a I was rich like I won the lottery
um you know I have I have have dollars
hit in my bank account uh I felt and
more important is like hope like oh my
gosh something finally worked like maybe
this could actually happen light at the
end of the tunnel and and then I just
modeled that strategy to keep getting
more and more and more growth also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight our
favorite lessons from the video that
will inspire you to remember what you
learned today and actually apply them
the worksheet will also give you space
to write down what your key takeaways
are and your specific plan of action to
make sure you're getting results if you
want the worksheet designed specifically
for this video absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there rule number five is
lower your expectations the goal today
though is just figure out if name cheap
the the right option that's it that's
our goal yeah that's our flossy one
truth and maybe you figure that out in
20 minutes watching on training or maybe
it takes you three hours of going
through it to kind of figure it out but
the idea is this is the goal for the
rest of the day that if you hit that
it's like hey pat on the back like I set
a goal and I hit it I said I was gonna
do it and I did it okay and if you
complete that you can always add more
you can always you know what I'm gonna
try actually building my website instead
of just researching I'm going to try
just making a homepage and just playing
around with some text and maybe doing
but it's not not the requirement for the
day okay so we're lowering we still got
a big vision and big mission to what
we're going to accomplish we're lowering
our expectations for what we want to do
today because we don't want to train
ourselves that you set goals and then
don't follow through and then you feel
like you know you don't feel great
because you said you're going to do 10
things and you did like half of one rule
number six is find another way it's one
thing if you're not trying and you're
not getting results but I was trying
every day all day long and just nothing
no results just zero and I remember I I
called him up and said I have to I have
I I quit I have to go find something
that makes me feel useful as a human
being um I wasn't I wasn't you know in
depression or suicidal or anything like
that but just I felt
useless and then I woke up the next day
and I felt um okay I can't quit yet
because I'm going to regret it if I do
and and I had um uh
there's a quote from Oprah that was in
my head that's just find another way to
stand you have to find another way to
stand like you don't quit you just find
another way to stand so like okay what's
another way that I can stand rule number
seven is take advantage of social media
you could do this okay where you do it
over something like Instagram live to
help build your Instagram audience up or
could just be a separate Zoom that you
do either for pay Members so hey as a
bonus you all Al get a one-on-one with
Grant okay right and do you sorry sorry
to interrupt you but then do you take
this and put it back into YouTube
meaning do you okay not all of the like
I have a Daily Show here not all of them
get cut for YouTube some of them if it's
really good it'll get cut my team just
decides of which one goes up um but yeah
so I I go live daily on Instagram uh and
that helps Instagram audience and also
creates content for other potential
platforms I mean this this could get cut
up into a million different ways for
different platforms depending on what
comes out of it um but that you could
have it as a bonus so hey here's my
membership and it costs x per month but
if you sign up for the annual deal you
also get a one-on-one with
Grant that then can be turned into
content right so you use it to you can
use it to get people into your program
um if you love it and and you want to do
more of it then uh maybe you have enough
members to to back it up if not then you
can do it for free
and people get to see you coaching so
that if it's free then it's public if
it's free then it's going to be online
and some people may not want it to be
public so say okay great well I've got a
I've got a coaching package and I've got
my membership program where you can
train with me every two weeks sure right
so the free gives you the attention that
then shows off you as a coach because if
you want to sell a membership program
where you're going to be coaching people
I need to see you as a coach right not
just a thought leader talking the camera
I need to see you like get get the ug
bug eyes like oh my God grant I can't
believe what you just said that saved my
life rule number eight is have Clarity I
think if you know what you want to do
that's the time to focus and build and
grow like if you want to build the
number one podcast for entrepreneurs
great then when somebody says hey do you
want to join me at truck driving school
you know you say no because you know
what you want to do you have the path
but if you don't know what you do and
like this you know you'll often go on
these ab and flows whenever you don't
know what to do the best thing is to say
yeah I'll join you at truck driver
school yeah 100% right like you go once
and you see right just like people who
decide that pizza is their favorite food
before they've tried Sushi or burritos
or anything else right you want to taste
it and try so if you don't have Clarity
over what you want you're not going to
figure out what you want sitting on the
couch you got to get out there and do
but if you do have Clarity over what you
want then then that's the time to put
the blinders on and focus I'm building
this thing don't distract me with your
other opportunities thank you I love you
but I got to build my thing rule number
nine is be strategic if you focused your
efforts and just got your 10 yeah that
then allows you to go hire more team to
go do more things and make things so
much easier so what's our clearest path
to get to 10 so if we now look at the
the YouTube channel they have to be
separate channels you can't have an
English and Chinese channel on the same
channel they are separate perfect yeah
where do I spend more time right now on
my Chinese Channel all right I won't
understand it yeah I could have Nina
look at it and say what is she
saying but it's it probably won't hit
that many people in China right but the
Chinese population in North America will
be able to watch it and see yeah you
you're probably going to be the only one
talking about complex trauma therapy on
YouTube in Chinese for now blue ocean
yeah and again you need 10 right we're
not trying to go eventually we're going
to go change the world yeah and be in
English and in Chinese and and down the
road billions of views and everything
great right cool but the path to be able
to get there is just again the sequence
what are the steps CU if you do
everything you're working with all these
consultants and all these different
things and English and Chinese and all
it's like then again there's lots of
opportunity but very little progress
right right stay focused stay focused
yeah so the first goal is get the 10
okay in Chinese focus on
Chinese do the webinar in Chinese for
Tim ask him about Connections in Chinese
you have your Chinese people that you
hired okay guys we need to get 10 people
that I'm going to work with one-on-one
yeah the YouTube content can be in
Chinese yeah because if you start making
regular Chinese content on YouTube for
complex uh trauma therapy right
everybody who's helping you can now use
that content yeah so the woman in
California can take some of those clips
and put that into the webinar and the
people in China that you hired can send
some of those videos or clip them and
and use them in their sales process
that's a good point and Tim can filter
some of his people and and send off this
video in China so like if you have
content going up people will discover
you on YouTube but your current Network
can also help share some of this stuff
for you yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a
good point you don't need millions of
views on your videos yet yet like we'll
get there right totally the mission yeah
but we need we need the right people
seeing it who might then hire you and Ru
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is start now
somebody's starting day one no resources
they they want to start putting content
into the world what is the number one
thing to think about is it process is it
you you mentioned some mindset things
but the actual doing if they were going
to start today what advice would you
give them you you pull out your phone
you know if you go on YouTube you turn
it
sideways you press record right like I
think it depends on the industry that
you're gonna you know what your Niche is
I I specialize in education thought
leadership um specifically
entrepreneurship person development if
that's you then people over focus on
like quality content they think of
quality of production the camera you use
the microphone you use the lighting and
and that barely matters like inside of
thought leadership education what
matters most is quality of thought can
you teach me something that I don't know
your job as a thought leader is to take
what's in your head and plant it into
your audience's head now if if you're a
videographer uh then yeah you're real
better look fire if you're a
videographer I don't want to see a bunch
of YouTube videos with like shaky hand
on your cell phone right I mean you're
not going to get hired for that but if
you're a speaker you're you're you want
to be an expert you're a coach your
trainer um you're selling Consulting
then it's it's not so much about how
good it looks it's more about how good
you are and we overthink and overanalyze
and over prepare and over script all of
our videos if you thought about how much
time you spent and I I mean I'm guilty
too go back and watch my first videos I
did all the same mistakes everybody else
did as well my first video I'm in a I'm
sitting down I'm in a suit super
uncomfortable we have the perfect
setting and lighting and all this stuff
behind us and and that was not that
video was not fire I mean it's it's
taken off because it's my first video
and people want to see what video number
one is but it's not like it was some
amazing video um because I sucked
because I was nervous and I didn't have
a great message so the most important
thing is just get the phone out and
imagine you're not speaking to a lens
but imagine you're speaking to a human
and it can either be yourself like
you're going to sit down with I would
sit down with 19-year-old Evan and like
here's what you need to know 19-year-old
Evan replace the camera lens with
person's face or an actual friend of
yours do you think that for people who
are looking at making an impact whether
that be online or through content or
speaking or any of those different
Avenues where do you you see that kind
of the next Horizon kind of like you
entered YouTube very early on what do
you think's next so I think it depends
on what your mission is right so for me
I've got a giant mission right I want to
impact the whole world and so how do you
do that well my hypothesis is that it's
content at
scale and if you're going to do content
at scale you've got two options long
form or short form like the platforms
are basically divided
Tik Tok and snap and Facebook and
Instagram are all short form content and
then YouTube is long form and YouTube
has shorts I guess as a combination but
there's YouTube on one side with the
long form and all the other content
which is short form and if if you want
to have an impact and really want to
make a difference I I think it's hard to
do it in 30 second little Clips so
that's a lot more inspiring but it's not
really making a huge imp imp if you're
trying to explain multif family
investing in a 42 second video like good
luck right so so but it's fine like the
shorts have their own path it's to
inspire but it's not really to to do
deep education and you're not really
doing any of the deep work just from the
clips so hopefully the clips Inspire
somebody to start down the path to learn
more about this thing tell me about your
daily
routine so I a morning routine and an
evening routine that are fairly
consistent and then I have a daily
routine that's different than other days
so so one day a week to do different
things terms of that kind of daily
routine that switches
up uh switching costs are real you know
even even in monotasking like we know
multitasking of of trying to do multiple
things at once but even monotasking to
do one thing at a time switching costs
are huge between jumping from one thing
to another so if I'm going to jump from
you to then going write my book to then
going and do do an email to then go it's
just it's too much of a switch you know
for me to get into the zone of writing
my book I need 45 minutes just to get
back to where I was from the last time I
left off from it so I try to assign
different things for different days now
I'm I'm in complete control pretty much
of my calendar that mean that'd be the
case for everybody but for what you can
control then being intentional about it
so for me monay Monday is my mentoring
day we have 40 people on my team I want
to be the kind of boss that when they
come in we make them a better humor and
then if they ever leave right so I spend
the whole day mentoring the people on my
team Tuesday is my YouTube day it's
content day I'm filming like if you do
not have time in your calendar to film
you're not going to film you're not
going to make the content if you wait
till you're inspired you're never going
to make anything so Tuesday is like
YouTube it's consistent it's in my
calendar every Tuesday I'm making
content Wednesday is my project day and
that is free it's open it's whatever I
want to work on because the
overscheduled entrepreneur usually ends
up hating their life for their business
because they never have time to work on
the things that that is new into their
company so my Tuesdays and Thursdays are
really jam-packed Wednesday in the
middle is completely open so yesterday
was a Wednesday I'm working on my book
next Wednesday I might work on something
completely different and it doesn't
always have to have a practical payoff
it's just something new fun experim
creativity is messy so Wednesday is a
messy day Thursday is my public facing
day interviews podcast today's a
Thursday when we're recording this right
so when we book these you know I 25
minutes on 5 minute break 25 minutes on
5 minute break so after this I'm going
into another 25 minute session then a 5
minute break and it's like my whole day
gets filled up doing other people's
shows and podcasts and it's it it's just
staying in the same energy like the
energy you're getting now I'm naturally
introverted and shy people don't get
that about me it doesn't come across but
the energy I'm showing up for your show
is the result of the five other shows
I've done before getting to you right
and I'm going to then take Ashish energy
and pour it into the next person right
so this you're you're not um sucking my
energy you're feeding me energy that I'm
then going to pour into the person who
comes afterwards right so like staying
in that energy zone is really important
that's how the day flies by and you get
into flow instead of having to jump from
one thing to the next Friday's my CEO
day um and I started with CEO hours like
if I had one hour what would I do if I
was a CEO like whatever that means to
you you're the CEO of your business now
what does that person do and I moved it
to be the whole day so like working on
the business instead of in the business
uh and then apply to the weekend like
Saturday's Funday Saturday is fun stuff
to do with my wife with the family not
like we just got a new house and there's
insane amounts of work that has to get
done but that's not Saturday Saturday is
what we're going to do for fun new
restaurant Street Festival drive-in
movie theater hang out like whatever but
fun and then Sunday's family admin day
where that's
the getting ready
for Costco and doing the laundry and
whatever and then and then it repeats
again on Monday and like that you're you
know your actions have to map to your
missions you have you have goals of what
you want to accomplish and not just like
business goals but a life what do you
what do you want to what is your dream
life look like and then you have to have
it in your calendar to do the actions
otherwise it just becomes you know a
hope so it that's my yeah that's my I
love it my life design man it's all life
design and it'll change and switch right
changes at the beginning I had nobody on
my team so I didn't have a a mentoring
day who was on mentoring nobody so get
to work now I have 40 people on my team
so I need to have a day focused on
mentoring and so the willingness this is
like the willingness to Pivot and change
especially an entrepreneurship because
you learn and grow right like
entrepreneurship is the greatest
personal development course of all time
you're learning and growing and
improving so it's crazy to think that
how you start and what you're working on
now is still going to be the same thing
in three years like your business has to
Pivot and change and your calendar has
to Pivot and change as you change and
evolve as a human being so wherever I'm
not happy especially consistently like
if it's a couple days in a row of not
being happy something is wrong in my
calendar like I'm just not doing the
right things anymore and I need to make
a change and if you can catch it early
enough then you don't end up having this
giant crisis where you have to make this
insane change right because you feel you
just fell completely out of alignment
with yourself throughout that Journey
there had to be some kind of perspective
on the monetary gain of the growth of
the gain of growth of of of that respect
was it always like I want to serve
people or how did you kind of get past
that first jump in the beginning where I
mean a lot of people aren't really
focused on serving they're just focused
on getting to a point where they can
serve sustainably if that makes sense
yeah so I mean I'm an entrepreneur I I
like making money you have you have to
make money if you have a big mission
like even if you want to serve I'm
Service First like Mission first purpose
first change the world first awesome and
you have to learn to make money so I I
say money can't be number one but it's
got to be in your top five if making
money is in your top hundred you're not
going to make make money and and then
you're just helping people on the
evenings and weekends which is still
great but it's not what you could be
doing right we've got over 50 people on
my team now because we know how to make
money if we didn't then I'd be doing
this my I probably wouldn't be on here
talking to you because I'd have to do a
million other things in my business just
to keep the you know the thing going and
so whether you're doing um advertising
or brand deals or sponsorships or you
have a product or service that you're
selling figuring out how you're going to
make money is really really really
important uh especially in the early
days uh because that's that is usually
the thing that kills most people's
dreams it kills most people's podcasts
and shows it's like man that was so much
fun to do but I can't justify the time
doing it anymore because I I need to
make money and so I have to go back and
get a job in what way did you get better
and what did you invest in so it was it
was mindset and skill set so in the
mindset I I'm introverted I'm shy that
doesn't come across on like interviews
like this but um I don't like the
spotlight I don't like being I don't
like being on stage um it makes me
nervous I it's not it's not enjoyable I
just came back from a three-day event in
Vegas where I was speaking with with
Gary Vee and um Patrick mavid and other
great speakers on stage and I don't like
being on stage I like the effect it
creates on the hallway afterward to go
help people so I'll I'm the only speaker
who sticks around and then I stay for
hours in the hallway talking to people
um because they'll come up to me and ask
me questions based off of my talk where
normally I would I wouldn't go up to
anybody and talk to them not because I'm
I'm too good for them but because I'm
afraid you know I'm introverted and shy
um but we still want to serve and so
that was that was a huge breakthrough
for me when I realized even though I'm
introverted and shy I still want to
serve I still want to help and all my
models at the time if you look at who's
on TV you just see the people who are
big mouth and extroverted in the life of
the party and like that wasn't me so I
thought oh like to do that you know I'm
at the same agency as M Robbins and
Grant Cardone and both of them very out
outwards focused and like the life of
the party and extrovert and love talking
to people um and just that wasn't me so
I I it took a while for me once I tied
it the service then it was an unlock
it's like it's not about me it's about
the people you can help and then that
became like oh okay but how does an
introvert make a lot of YouTube videos
and win I don't know but we'll just
figure it out you know like let's try
let's see what happens um and then the
second part of that was was getting help
and communication and getting once I
decided to take more seriously that I
realiz oh I should be doing more than
than um yeah just getting coaching and
getting help and watch my videos back
and becoming a better speaker um so
people can get there a lot faster it's
not like oh once you have a thousand
subscribers or 100,000 subscribers or a
million subscribers or whatever it is
then instantly everything gets better
it's much more but are you are you good
enough are you have the skill set and
the talent and the mindset to actually
make great content and obviously the
more repetition you put in the better
but but getting coaching and getting
help and getting people to give you
guidance um really helped me too talk to
me a little bit about the service
mentality and that service above self
mentality that I mentioned because I
feel like it's really um a part of your
core it's something that you really
really
authenticate so I haven't heard of uh
service above self before but I'm also
not part of rotary and um I think
ultimately service is the path to
self I think I think humans are built to
serve I think if you're not happy it's
because you're not
serving every day we all want to wake up
and feel like what we do matters to
somebody else we want to feel like the
job we're going to or the business we're
creating or whatever we're going to do
today is going to have an impact on
somebody else and some people you and I
and probably most of your listeners we
want to change the world we want to have
a big impact we want to go and you know
have our message reach wide and far but
not because of us but because of the
impact that we want to create and other
people like my wife
Nina she doesn't want to have a big
mission but she serves the 25 closest
people to us she's the glue for our
family remember everybody's birthdays
and what they're doing and what they
need and what they're going through and
all of the stuff that I
forget probably I should get better at
but everybody wants to serve serving
others is hardwired into our brain did
did functional MRIs on people's brains
and found that serving other people hits
the same part of your brain as having
food and having sex so it's like
literally hardwired into your brain that
you need this to be a functioning happy
member of society I think some people um
have experienced things like act of
kindness you know how nice it is to buy
the coffee with the person behind you in
line or hold the door or those kinds of
things and those moments are great and
keep doing them but I think everybody
also has a much deeper level of service
where I believe that your purpose comes
from your pain that whatever you
struggled the most with as a human is
what you want to help other people
through and so when you can see somebody
who is going through the thing that you
went through and feels hopeless and lost
and is struggling and doesn't see a way
out and then they spend 8 minutes with
you you say hey you know what it's okay
it's like I went through that too and
here's how to get out and then you see
hope in their eyes for the first time
and like you made that happen you caused
that and then that's that little that's
a that's a spark in their life that can
change the entire trajectory of their
life that's the thing to get addicted to
like that's what we all want and I think
we're living in a world now where a lot
of people find zero meaning in their
work they're driving to a job that they
hate and I'm just trying to ignite some
passion in people Evan I find you so
interesting because you're an introvert
and and and generally speaking
introverts get energy for being alone
that's kind of like part of it um also
call me out if that's wrong but what's
interesting is you get a lot of energy
from helping people which usually in
context is around people yeah so it's
just interesting thing with you where
it's like you keep saying you're an
introvert but then when we were meeting
you were like pretty chill and laidback
and then the second that we start
talking about you like it's like you
were just taking energy yeah from the
Environ so it was just it's interesting
I don't know that I'll speak on behalf
of all introverts but you know my own
story would be I struggled with this a
lot my biggest fight with my agent was
like you need to be famous Evan it's
like I don't want to be famous why do I
want to be famous I don't want to be
famous and he's like I don't understand
you everybody I work with wants to be
famous like okay cool I don't know I
don't want to be famous and so we fought
for years until he said you don't
understand you know that the if you get
more famous people hear the message and
it's always been about the message and
so hanging out in most like I remember
being in San Diego this still happens
this is like late last year a couple
months ago in San Diego uh Grant Cardone
was doing this event on in San Diego and
it was on a boat and the boat was going
to have like Tim TBO and like all these
CBS and and you went on a boat cruise
and you come back and because it was
like three or four hours on the boat and
I'd have no way to get back if I didn't
like it I didn't
go right it's like oh three hours on a
boat and I have no way to get back what
if I hate it right like yeah I need an
escape plan I got to go um but what I
realized was introverts love to serve
yeah like we want to serve too we want
to feel like the work we do has meaning
and matters to people and so that's what
I lean in and focus on and most
conversations do drain me if you want to
talk about the weather or I don't know
what do people talk about I I don't know
what people talk about I suck at all
that stuff I hate it it drains me like I
really I I do not like networking events
it drains me to no end I hate introduce
myself I hate asking answering like well
what do you do all of that like I never
talk to the person on the airplane next
to me yeah all of it zero uh but if you
can hit on like a couple of if you're an
entrepreneur or you love salsa dancing
or League of Legends uh we could
probably have like a really deep five
hour conversation and so I think at
least for me it may not be for all
introverts we love meaningful deep
powerful ations and none of the surface
fluffy stuff and that's the stuff that
um really will drain me and I'll avoid
yeah as much as possible yeah can you
talk a little bit about the team and and
how you feel about creating a team
around you and how that works well teams
are are critical to grow and not
everybody like most small businesses are
just a solo preneur um but if you want
to scale and grow then you have to be
able to work with the team and you have
to like managing people a lot of people
don't like managing people they like
just being by themselves but if you want
to get you want to get a return out of
it and you want to have fun then you
have to you have to want to mentor and
lead and grow and learn to manage a team
I think I think you've got to First be
connected like for you you might not
love digging
ditches uh but you got to connect to the
mission of like hey this is for somebody
this is for somebody's home this is
we're making people healthier we're
we're helping people's Liv like you have
to connect to why you're doing the work
if you don't enjoy the actual like
digging ditches or you connect to like
hey this is a good workout and I'm
getting some vitamin D while we're doing
this yeah right exactly but but a lot of
people have a hard time moving from
digging ditches to then being the person
who manages 50 people who are digging
ditches and you have to love people
training them you have to love mentoring
them like even you going and
volunteering to talk to the Junior
Achievement kids speaks to your
willingness to mentor and train and
guide and and just try to give back
right that's what you have to be doing
for your team you're basically a little
further ahead than them and you become
an almost Father Figure or or uncle or
older brother depending on the age gap
between people on your team to help them
become better humans you know the goal
is they become better humans when
they're with you they're not just
collecting a paycheck I encourage
entrepreneurs to go through um a
three-step process which is eliminate
automate delegate okay so you look at
the work that you're doing and maybe you
shouldn't be doing it at all like before
you give it to somebody else maybe it
just shouldn't get done and there's
there's often things that we're doing
that we think are really high value that
then turn out to like to not matter and
we may not even notice it right I mean
before Movie Makers I had a mastermind
that I ran in Toronto for entrepreneurs
and when people joined um we took uh
minutes like notes of what was happening
like I took minutes this before AI could
do it for you and transcripts like I
wrote down minutes for what everybody
said and homework and assignments and
everything and um there was one month
where I forget what happened like I was
going away the next day or something and
I didn't get the notes out to people
after the meeting nobody
cared like no response no message no
like Hey where's the minutes where's the
notes and I and so I didn't do it again
next month nobody cared it's like wow
I've been spending all this time
on something that like nobody cared
about that I thought was high value but
was actually zero value for people um
maybe it was even negative value maybe I
was annoying them with it I don't know
uh and so eliminate first you know so I
mean a lot of entrepreneur might be
frustrated with their accounting and
bookkeeping uh you cannot eliminate that
right like that has to get done yeah he
will run into problems if you try to
eliminate that from your business right
and I was going to go into that for you
yeah keep going yeah the government will
come for you that is a big problem
unless you live in some country that
that doesn't move to the moon or
something but um yeah you know that's a
problem so you can't eliminate that but
but there's a lot of things that we're
doing that just should not be done they
just be completely eliminated the next
is automate so before giving it to a
human give it to technology so use
software use tools use AI use QuickBooks
use like there's a lot of things there's
software and tools for a lot of things
that you should should start applying
into your business bu uh that can save a
lot of manh hours um and then you get to
delegate so eliminate automate and then
delegate and so these are the things
that still have to get done but should
not be done by you so in eliminate they
shouldn't be done at all in automate
they need to be done but should be done
by a human and then in delegate it's it
it should be done but shouldn't be done
by you has to be done by another human
and that's where you start to scale and
build and create I think you have to
trust your gut that's what they say yeah
because opportunities are coming like
that all the time but the problem is
they don't make sense a lot of
times because that shouldn't be coming
to you or or you're not qualified or why
am I thinking about that or I didn't go
to school for that or that's not what I
should be doing
right and so we're missing all these
opportunities every day that are coming
by so you might there might be some
person walking down the street and for
whatever thought in your head I should I
should say hi to them why would I do
that I don't say hi to people I'm
introver I'm shy I don't talk to people
right like okay how you doing
I and you and you say you're inter no
but like but that doesn't no no but I
don't do that that often but if I had
the idea for then I would right so it's
it's just I've had to train myself to
just not think about my thoughts and
just do it and just do it trust Robins
five 4321 even faster than that right
like trust that great ideas flow through
you no one give that
shut now the caveat is if you're in a
really negative mood that's where you
need patience right like if somebody
cuts you off in traffic oh yeah I'm GNA
drive past that guy just to see what he
looks like right you
know but that's that's where we trust
our impulses we will trust our impulses
when we're in a really negative state of
mind but when we're in a really positive
one that's where we pause and we need to
flip it when you're in a really negative
State of Mind some bad news happened
don't make a a a a rash call in the
moment right like something negative
happened the whole world has not falling
apart pause reflect sleep on it like
come back to it the next day and still
see if you want to do that thing or not
but when something great is happening
and you're in a positive spirit and an
idea comes to you that's the time that
you go do something about it people are
watching this episode and like I want to
go do like do it now because you're
going to wake up tomorrow and the energy
will be gone and you're starting over
again and the opportunity will pass you
by when you're having those days what do
you tell yourself or who helps you on
those days because we can't all have 10
out of 10 days right like we wish we
could but they're not always going to be
a 10 out of 10 we have to accept that
sometimes there's a two out of 10 or a
four out of 10 what do you do on those
days yeah
so my habits save me for most of most of
the time um
I almost every day will have a believe
walk and and that's part of my morning
routine I wake up I get outside I go for
a believe walk and that's getting fresh
air but I'm also I'm also listening to
one of my own videos and responding to
people in my community to remind me of
the thing that I'm doing um I haven't
this part's a little weird where like I
haven't wanted to quit people like what
about quitting on you I haven't thought
about quitting ever on YouTube uh it's
too connected now to like serving in
what I do but do I have days that are um
lower energy or do I have days where I'm
not thinking big enough oh I mean
especially that one 100% you know um
yeah I think I think if you're
consistently thinking about quitting you
have to you have to understand the
reason why is it because you're afraid
or is it because you don't want to do
things I think I think people stay in
things too long like when people say
don't quit don't quit I think people
should off often quit on businesses
sooner relationship sooner jobs sooner
because you'll never win doing work that
you hate but if the reason that you're
quitting is because you're afraid that's
not a good enough reason um and so where
I am challenging myself to do the most
work is
on bigger thinking like the biggest
frustration for me is okay so if I'm at
three and a half million subscribers how
do I get to 35 right and how do I live
in that vibe
consistently um if I'm feeling super low
energy I'll take a
break you know like I had people over at
my house not too long ago for my
birthday I've invested into a bunch of
different entrepreneurs and I Mentor
them once a week and they came over I
don't really celebrate my birthday so I
like okay come on over for my birthday
and and we'll hang out together and we
spent five days together and like all
day all night fell behind on like
everything I was doing and then I had uh
the Monday where like everybody went
home kind of Sunday night and uh like
okay I'm
I'm I'm not doing anything today you
know like my voice started to get a
little sore it wasn't as like it was so
much high energy I need to I need this
is today's recovery day I think I post
on Instagram like recovery day today
I'll see you tomorrow and I just checked
out of everything that I was doing how
do you get to that level because there's
so much noise isn't there there's so
many people competing and people get
this is a bit of a long- windy question
but people get very disheartened because
they don't get immediate results so they
say oh it doesn't work so what would you
say to those
people well I I don't know if you've
seen my journey I post it on my website
so if anybody wants to see how how uh
slowly I took at the beginning to get
going uh people use it inspiration um I
post every year so I started uh in 2009
and every may I post where where I'm at
in terms of my subscriber growth and the
first year was 25 subscribers and the
second year I like 100 subscribers
something in my fifth year I still had
700 subscribers or something like that
and that's like people will say how did
you not quit like how do you keep going
how you're five and you only have 700
something subscribers like you might
want to go find something
else you know like it's not working go
do something else uh
so I I mean I just I love doing it and I
think that's why you have to love the
process of the thing that you're doing
and if anybody people you know I
challenge people to do this because it's
a fun thing but a lot of times people
will take take that graphic of how I'm
doing year by year and then they they uh
put it into an Instagram post or video
or tweet or something to say that
they're beating Evan carmichel because
most people are beating me most people
by year five you know already have more
than 700 something subscribers so you
can say that you're ahead of me the only
difference is I kept going you know I
just I just kept going I kept making it
I kept creating content I kept sharing
and when people ask well how did you
keep going like how did you not quit
what gave you the inspiration and reason
to keep going I always focus on who I
was serving instead of who I
wasn't okay and that made a a huge shift
for me because we all most of us are in
the who I'm not serving game right even
now I've got three whatever million
subscribers why is it not four why is it
not five why is it not 10 you know you
know what the the who I'm not game is
never ending but who you are serving
right now can make all the difference in
the world so that those 25 people in my
first year like those are 25 people who
subscribe to my channel you know like
that's pretty cool I thought that was
pretty cool if you go and you speak at a
at a library or a YMCA or my first
speaking gig was at a YMCA and 25 people
show up that's pretty cool now I thought
I would think that's pretty cool my
first speaking I had three people show
up so if 25 people showed up that'd be
pretty cool and so if you can if you can
re-engineer your mind to to think about
that that hey if I have 25 people or 100
people or a thousand people or however
big your audience is it doesn't mean
that you stop growing and you get
complacent and you just only live in
gratitude for what you've got but if you
focus on serving them instead of who
you're not serving it does a couple
things one it's a lot more fun you to
feel like you matter and that the work
you're doing is having an impact on
people
that fun we all want to feel like we're
doing something that matters and if you
can actually connect the thing that
you're you're doing actually matters to
somebody maybe not the world you and I
want to serve the world cool and if you
knew that you did something today that
helped at least one person it's easy to
have the motivation to keep going it and
doing it again the next day the next day
the next day and two the people who you
are serving will take you to the people
who you're not serving you know like if
you keep serving your people well
they'll tell them they'll tell their
friends about you say hey go watch this
person's video um and you never know the
impact that you're you're having on
people on your mission that you're on
what challenges with that format that
you've built uh have you faced for
what's next and what's been the
advantage of that format for what you've
been able to build in the impact that
you're making in the world my biggest
limitation is still lack of
belief
so people say but you're the believe guy
it's like yeah but I believe in myself
to to do the things that I've done now
but to do the next the next big thing I
don't believe myself to do the next big
so I still need the channel for myself
because I want to wake up and have Oprah
Winfrey or Steve Jobs or Elon Musk or
whoever it is Whispering messages in my
ear to get me going to do the next thing
um one of my my uh talk about the format
of of giving tribute to other people uh
at the beginning it was just hey I've
learned this from these people and I
think you might be able to learn too I
was just helping to shortcut the path
cuz my my worst day in my first business
was when I said I quit on my business
partner and I woke up the next day and
said I can't quit yet because I'm going
to regret this if I don't figure this
out at least at least if it doesn't work
out fine but at least know that I gave
it everything because I don't want to
look back and say ah I wish I just tried
a little bit harder but I couldn't keep
going the way that I was going so I had
to find another path and the thing that
came to me was I can't be the first
person to try to solve this problem like
somebody's figured this out why don't I
just model success like that wasn't
model success wasn't words that I would
use you know it's probably a lot more
clumsy but I can't be the first person
to figure this out somebody's done it
and that's where I studied Bill Gates
it's like Bill Gates had a like who's
got a software company I had a software
company who's got a successful software
company Bill Gates came to mind like
this was not very Advanced planning it's
just top of Dome uh so okay how did
Microsoft get started and how did he
build like not so much how did how does
Bill Gates make an extra million dollars
now who cares but like0 to one how did
he do that and it was through
Partnerships and and learning how he
applied that in Microsoft I brought that
to my business and quickly after I had
my first check for
$135,000 and that may not seem like a
lot but when you're making 300 bucks a
month like 135k it's like holy cow this
is a grand slim here and more
importantly I could do that again that
was just is one deal I could close more
deals so the idea the strategy there was
model success find people who have done
this and put that to use in your
business or your life and so I I then
went on this mission to continue
learning how I can model other people's
success and then I that eventually
became a YouTube channel where I shared
a lot of messages um a surprising
benefit of that has been I've gotten to
meet some of these people you know like
I was just profiling some of them and
then now I get to do interviews with
them or go hang out with them or go to
their houses and some of them become
friends which was never part of the idea
of what I could do it's just hey I love
your
message I'm trying to get it out to the
world cuz if I learn from it maybe other
people like me can learn from it and
it's been amazing to be able to foster a
lot of those connections too I think if
we look at Instagram for example it's a
lot of people sharing all of their best
moments it's their highlight reel of
their life and all these awards that you
won and the Beautiful Photoshop Beach
pict sure and all that and I think
there's still definitely a lot of that
and a lot of people who are too afraid
to ever show any kind of weakness um
even some people in the personal
development space are like too afraid to
show their weakness uh and then some
people are very candid and upfront and
share everything and that becomes their
brand um you know if you look at Gary
he's he's very open about how he
struggles with candid uh being candid
having candid conversations um Mel
Robbins is very open to sharing in like
her brand of personal development is
basically all the stuff that she's
trying to figure out for herself yeah
she says and then she she learns and
then she teaches uh so I think you know
authenticity is a big buzzword people
are throwing around I think it can
definitely help connect people to you I
think it just depends on who you're
following um there's a lot of people who
who come off as perfect still and they
they grow their following doing that and
there's a lot of people who lean into
the other side and show all the the
warts and um that attracts people as
well I love that showing all the warts
showing all the warts and and you get to
decide who you want to be right I think
ultimately you'll be happier if you show
the warts and the what you're insecure
about and like James aler friend of the
channel um he likes to say for his
podcast that he basically thinks about
what's the what's the problem that he's
most embarrassed about right now that
like someone like him should have
figured out mm and then tell people
about
it like what are you struggling with now
that you should have already figured out
by now and then and then tell people and
and that makes him very endearing and
that's why a lot of people love him when
you think of an entrepreneur what do you
think if you were going to Mentor a
young person what do you think that the
one or two or three characteristics that
you'd really want to see in somebody is
before you said you know what yeah I
think they're GNA they're going to make
it happen no matter what I think there's
some characteristics to winning so a lot
of the ones you mentioned too like
persistence and dedication and hard work
it's like that is
definitely need it for entrepreneurs and
they're just characteristics of winning
like you could win and not be an
entrepreneur and have persistence and
dedication and faith and hard work I
think to to succeed as an entrepreneur
you have
to want to make something different for
your life and for others because there's
there's always a path that's laid out
for you you know if you're talking to
kids like your parents have a have an
ideal plan for you they love for you to
go and do and your school and guidance
counselors there's there's these very
easy laid out plans of what you're
supposed to
do you go to school and then you go to
college and then you get a job and or or
you don't go to college and you follow
in like family footsteps and whatever it
is but there's there's very easy paths
to follow for your career where being an
entrepreneur usually means you have to
step far outside those predetermined
paths for you and that's hard you know
when nobody in your family has done and
when you don't have Role Models or
mentors or or you know people like you
to talk to that's really really hard to
step outside those predetermined paths
and that's what an entrepreneur is
willing to do is like not get stuck in
the grooves that have been laid out for
them and they're going to set a new path
for themselves it doesn't mean they'll
be super successful there's lots of
entrepreneurs who are below the poverty
line or like just making enough money or
are are it's just them and they're you
know they're just getting by like most
entrepreneurs are not Mega wealthy
um but they're doing it because they
just want to create their own path for
themselves and for the people around
them walk us through an average every
day for you as a high
performer well average every day or or
when I was on tour doing 90 Days Tour on
tour on tour on tour so part of the
reason for doing the tour was I was
afraid of speaking and i' done a lot of
speaking but it was always just like uh
you you speak and then it you're scared
and then I come back home and then I'm
fine and then I was I I wanted to get
rid of this fear of speaking and so I
thought okay I'm just going to go and do
23 cities and every four days speak
again every three four days like new new
city do it again do it again do it again
do it again get my reps in and that
became the starting point so every
fourth day basically I was in a new city
speaking uh every fourth day we also had
to travel we still had to work uh and I
wanted to spend some time with Nina it
was me Nina and my cameraman Danny for
90 days
together Hotel hopping Airbnb hopping it
was it was a pretty chaotic but fun ride
when I go to events I ask people to give
me advice and feedback the people who I
respect on um my videos for example and
I'll always leave with hey tell me why I
suck tell me where it
sucks and I know it doesn't suck but
what I'm doing is giving them permission
to be honest to say okay here's what I
would actually fix she'll say hey Evan
it doesn't suck but I would fix these
you know one two three things to get the
the real advice they're not hiding the
truth but why am I able to do that well
because I'm grounded and knowing that
the stuff is good and I'm grounded and
knowing that I love the work that I'm
that I'm doing right so it allows for
the push to go off and do more the
problem becomes is like you're why are
you going to do more is it is it
grounded in in service in and kindness
and trying to help people or is it
grounded in no because if I get that
Lamborghini it's going to make me look
good to people who I don't care about
right that was it right there yeah right
so it's like service but you have to
feel connected to the service you have
to feel like the thing matters so if you
put out this episode and five people
watch it or five million people watch it
it's I would tell myself that it's
having an impact on at least one person
that even even this even if you never
I've had shows where I'm like their
first guest and it never gets published
right but hopefully in something I say
today maybe it moves you aish forward
and it has that little spark because
I've seen it enough where like four
years later 5 years later eight years
later we meet at some event and say you
know that thing you told me back in 2022
dude that like changed everything like
I've seen enough of that happen that it
makes me realize that this is really
important that like this work that I do
to help really matters when it comes to
serving or just building that belief
within yourself where do you think most
people go wrong when it comes to trying
to build more belief and actually start
creating a life that you know they're
fulfilled by not just you know okay
with I don't think they're thinking
about it as much as making
money like if you if just your question
like what what mistake did people make
on building a business that fulfills
them I don't think most people are
asking themselves what would be a
business that fulfills me like that's
the biggest problem they're not asking
the question they might be saying what's
a business that makes me money they
might be saying what's a business that
maybe can have a big impact but if you
say what's a business that fulfills me I
don't think people are really asking
that question and that's a great
quarterly check-in because the things
that fulfilled you last year may not
fulfill you anymore you've maybe you've
grown past them maybe that was a fun
little experiment and you don't like
that thing as much anymore it doesn't
fulfill you anymore and you need to move
on I think a lot of people stay in the
same business or same relationship for
too long because it doesn't actually
fulfill them anymore so the biggest
mistake is just not asking the question
ask a question you'll get some good
answers what advice would you give to
folks who are listening to this who know
that they're destined for more and what
message would you like to leave them
with today just to know that it's
possible that whatever that dream in
your head is that it's actually probably
even small compared to what you're
capable of and that it's possible and
that people with less intelligence and
less resources than you you're Heroes a
lot of them started with less than what
you have right now you have Steven to
pay attention to you know a lot of your
Heroes didn't have anybody and they
figured it out and so if they can you
can too and it requires a different way
of thinking it requires uh a different
way of acting it requires you maybe
saying no to some people and then saying
yes to new people and new opportunities
in your life but your dream is possible
and you just have to wake up every day
and take one more step towards making
momentum happen towards it because I
think for a lot of people the biggest
thing they're missing is just momentum
we talk about James aler something that
he had mentioned on Twitter one one day
and that really stuck with me was he
added up all the minutes uh and all the
minutes which add up to hours that we
spend like watching TV and being in
traffic and being in the restroom and
being on Twitter and on social media and
checking emails and texting people and
it it came out to this ridiculous amount
of hours per day and then I think the
question was posed like you know imagine
what you could be creating instead of
doing this doing these other things and
so to your point you were able to to
crank this out in a very short amount of
time yeah and and I I started on a
Tuesday we had our Instagram live
session a Tuesday we finished at you
know 3 o' and the book is called
momentum
so when she asked when are you going to
start well how do I start it next year
like it's called momentum I kind of have
to start like right now if I'm going to
call it momentum right yeah if I was
going to call it procrastination then
that's fine next year great uh so I had
to start right away and I got some words
done that day I got some words done the
next day on the Wednesday Wednesday is
my project day so it's completely open
so I had time to to work on things but
then the day after that was Thursday and
Thursday is my public facing day where
it's wall to--all interviews and podcast
and like we're recording this on the
Thursday I don't know when it goes live
but it's wall toall 25 minutes on 5
minute break 25 like the whole day it's
like well I'm not going to get any work
done on on my book on Thursday like
there's no way and I write this like my
insecurities and concerns like I don't
want to lose momentum on the book
because I'm going to day three and
there's zero time to do it and then on
Thursday two people cancel back to back
last minute so now I have like this hour
in the middle of the day to actually do
something and so we think about like
what do we normally do if if something
happens if I couldn't make this podcast
for some reason Freddy I'm sick Freddy
what that happens people cancel
reschedule stuff always happens what do
we do in that time do we do we actually
be intentional with it probably I would
have I don't know checked email checked
my social media something probably not
the highest leverage because I had
something else planned it got last
minute change so I'm going to do
something low value but like I got an
hour let me write this is this is
fantastic right and I think we actually
can find these moments where we are
wasting time or doing lowlevel activity
um where we stay busy I think a lot of
entrepreneurs stay busy on things that a
lot of times don't matter like we do a
lot of work that's not very efficient
we're distracted by a bunch of things
and the actual outcome of that thing is
actually not that consequential versus
taking action on thing that actually
means the most to us so I think we have
those moments and again I had a full
schedule I got 40 something people on my
team I'm running multiple businesses and
agencies and I had no time planed to
write this
book on top of that we had a health
scare the middle of it where my wife got
this lump above her breast that we have
to go to the doctor and like was insane
she's okay like I talk about that in the
book uh but that killed an entire day
I'm behind and everything and yet you
still got the book done 40,000 words in
five days if you're trying to get your
journey going on YouTube cool take a
bite and see try making videos try doing
Vlogs try doing interviews try doing
direct the camera try doing speeches try
the things that you see and expect to
suck at all of them at the beginning
you're not going to be good because you
don't have the skill set yet doesn't
mean you suck as a human you just you
don't have the skill set yet but the
thing to pay attention to is did you
enjoy it how did you feel after doing it
you had that interview and it's easy to
go back if you go back and watch your
first interview it's a train wack it
mean you're awkward and nervous and ask
the wrong questions and you can look
back on it and say oh my gosh I should
have done that and you can go over it in
your head a million times but like but
did you like it you know like was it fun
to do do you want to go back and do it
again did it give you more energy than
it took and if it's a yes then that's a
great sign to keep
going and so a lot of people stop on
YouTube because they don't get immediate
results because they're not doing
something that they feels authentic to
them um and they're focused on who
they're not serving instead of who they
are serving um and they just judge
themselves too harshly for not having
the skill set yet like you don't just
get on a snowboard and go down the hill
you fall 80 times on your first run and
then you fall 50 times on your second
run right and you just you get better as
you go when did you start the habit of
replacing those negative thoughts with
positive ones and then when did you
start to see them take root and actually
manifest in your life I don't know that
I made a conscious choice that like now
I'm going to replace this thought with
this thought I think it's just as a
result of being in the industry so long
watching so many like if you think about
what I do and how many videos I watch of
how many successful people they all have
some core themes to them and whether
it's entrepreneurs or athletes or
artists or musicians or whoever they
have similar themes and and you know
turning lemonade or turning lemons into
lemonade you know turning a negative
into a positive is is a consistent theme
across everybody and so I think it just
it happened
subconsciously just by being in the
environment of having those people
around me virtually to the point where I
was doing that exercise being forced to
sit with negative thoughts and it it I
had changed but I didn't notice like I
don't there was no moment of coming out
of the Cocoon and now I'm a butterfly it
just slowly became here I am as a
butterfly gotcha so it was just going
through the process yeah it's it's like
imagine if you were working out your
legs every day you don't you don't you
don't see a day-to-day difference right
there's no one moment like oh you did
one extra hard set and now you've got
these Rippling calves ready to go right
but I think the only difference was I
wasn't
even consciously training it was just
because it was in my environment and I
think that happens for a lot I think
that happens for most people just in a
negative way you're constantly watching
news and Twitter streams and all of this
negativity and all of a sudden you know
you start to become a negative person
because of all the things that are
happening around you but it's not that
you can pinpoint one thing that that was
the moment you became negative or even
notice that you're becoming negative is
just happening and so that's the power
of when you shift your environment and
you're controlling what you're consuming
into your you know into your brain so I
was conscious of what I was consuming I
wasn't conscious about a lot of the
transformation that happened as a result
it's only in looking back or doing
exercises like that um that I notice the
difference I mentioned grief as a caveat
because that's the only one that I don't
think you can you can just positive your
way out of sure you know like I think
you just have to feel your way through
grief at least me you know I have I
haven't lost my parents so that's
awesome but um my family dog was like
that was the only time I haven't made
videos in the past 10 years is when my
family dog passed away wow uh because he
died on filming day and I just couldn't
film and I I could have if it was
anything else if I was jealous if it was
angry if I got cut off on traffic if I
lost a bunch of subscribers I don't know
something else happened like okay come
on let's go car like film but I just
didn't feel right to push past it to
film you know like I film with a
concussion and a broken neck and all
this other stuff but when when Toby
passed like I don't know it doesn't feel
right to just brush it away and so I
just have to feel
this to achieve ultimate Freedom watch
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there practice gives you
ultimate Freedom the more you practice
the better you get at something the more
skill you are at it the more information
you have the more it actually allows you
to play more have more fun be more
flexible and have ultimately more
freedom